as apple fans are eagerly awaiting tim
cook to get back on stage and announce
new products like the 27-inch imac and
the mac mini we just got confirmation on
three specific apple products that are
getting ready to launch and ship very
soon here two of them we anticipated but
there is one product that makes
absolutely no sense at least initially
and in this video we will cover what
that is and why apple would be replacing
it so early this info comes from the
eurasian economic mission database
filings pointing to three products being
imported into india and getting prepped
to launch soon now this has me really
excited for the possibilities because as
you've probably seen lately we've been
getting disappointment after
disappointment with many new product
release dates getting delayed but at the
same time some people are going to be
really confused and upset if the device
that they just bought is getting
replaced but i'll explain why it makes
sense and how these products will fit
together in apple's lineup the first of
these three is of course the new iphone
se3 we've been looking forward to this
phone for the past few months because
everybody has been expecting it to
finally be updated and drop the old
design finally getting rid of the home
button while either adding face id or a
new touch id power button allowing for a
bigger screen like the iphone 10. and
with that of course upgraded hardware
like cameras instead of the super old
parts from the iphone 8 which gets
absolutely smoked even by the cheaper
pixel 4a which has already been replaced
and with that a full spec upgrade across
the board was expected to finally make
it competitive and since it's going to
be around for a long time it could
include mac safe which has been a game
changer in the newer phones of course it
would still have an lcd display and use
budget components to be priced at 399
dollars and looking like a say a smaller
iphone 10r that would be enough to pull
people away from android and get them to
upgrade from older iphones but nope
dylan dkt recently updated a suite from
last year on the iphone se given us the
bad news that this model has been pushed
back until
2024.
i can't believe it 2024.
this means that this upcoming se will
feature the same size that we've had for
eight years now and with most of the
components being from the iphone 8. now
sure the processor will be updated to
the a15 bionic which is crazy for a 399
dollar phone but honestly even the a13
is still more than powerful enough for
everybody that is buying it now this cpu
will help with battery life a bit which
is good since the current sc only lasted
3 hours and 38 minutes in mr who's the
boss's latest test where even the 13
mini lasted almost twice as long but can
it really help enough since the biggest
headline feature the addition of 5g
sucks more power than the current lte
and the battery will likely stay exactly
the same the tiny one whereas current
competitors like the budget pixel have
batteries over twice the size to me this
just proves that apple is only making
this change to market the buzzword 5g
for those people that still want to keep
touch id in the classic design that
they're used to and to stop using the
a13 and put the a15 chip into more
products which does streamline and it
reduces costs which will be very
important for the new surprise product
that will be launched which will likely
take the a14 processor from the next
product that's going to be launched that
we're talking about that is the ipad air
5 which really needs an update coming
into india with two new model numbers
the air 5 will replace the 4 which has
aged super fast even though it is the
first non-pro ipad to use the square
edge design even when it launched we
told people to consider buying an old
2018 ipad pro instead for not much more
because of everything extra that it
offers like 120 hertz promotion higher
brightness quad speaker systems and more
and once the new m1 ipad pros came out
the difference in features and
performance was even bigger with the 8
core processor and graphics much faster
storage thunderbolt 4 and having the
better cameras and mics the center stage
feature double the storage and so much
more for only a 200 price difference and
if that wasn't bad enough soon after
that apple updated their other ipads
which also now include the center stage
cameras even for the 329 budget ipad and
the mini 6 finally got the same new
redesign but one up the air with better
cameras mics a flash along with the new
a15 processor for a hundred dollars less
and at this point the only reason to buy
the air is if you absolutely have to
have a new design ipad with a big screen
and it has to be at that price point and
brand new instead of used because other
than that right now you'd be better off
with pretty much any other ipad so how
is apple going to fix this well first
off it is pretty obvious that it will
get the a15 just like the se and with
that 5g support to keep up with the pack
according to maka takara the new air
will also get the 12 megapixel center
stage camera with quad led true tone
flash which is also a given since the
cheaper mini has this now it's not
expected but could come our quad
speakers instead of the current dual
speakers hidden behind four grilles and
makatakara also mentioned that it could
be getting the same lidar and dual
camera setup as the pro models have all
of this is really required to make it
competitive and worthy now personally i
would like it to come with more than 64
gigabytes of storage and then having a
hefty price upgrade to get to 256 but
this isn't really likely knowing apple
and unfortunately the other leaks that
we've saw like the oled display that
digitimes claimed would come in early
2022 have been delayed and this ipad
will stick to the same lcd screen with
limited contrast and brightness so what
about the third and final new product
that was registered and is now being
tested in india with the model numbers
8257 and a2761
well reports are that this is another
ipad and some people were speculating
that it could be a different size of the
air but that makes no sense in other set
it could be finally the mini led version
of the 11 inch ipad but that also
doesn't make a lot of sense because you
would have to do a price hike just like
the 12.9 inch ipad had and because we
already have info that these will be
launching in the fall with the m2
processors the verdict seems to be that
this surprise ipad is a replacement for
the 9th generation ipad that launched
less than 5 months ago
but how the heck is this possible why
would apple replace a perfectly good
ipad that just came out only six months
later well there could be a few reasons
first off apple has actually done this
before but it has been about 10 years in
2012 they launched the third generation
ipad in the spring and then just half a
year later that same year they replaced
it with the ipad 4 which made a lot of
people upset this ipad looked identical
but packed more powerful hardware like
the a6x processor significantly better
front cameras and the two most important
features being connectivity both wired
and wireless the 4th gen ipad got
airplay and a worldwide 4g modem which
was a big deal and with that of course
we are expecting this updated ipad the
budget one to also feature 5g now
personally i don't think that this is a
big enough deal at all and certainly not
enough to make it worth replacing an
ipad just six months later so there has
to be more the other feature that the
4th gen got was the lightning port
finally getting rid of the 30 pin
connector and if we look at what's
happening now apple is finally close to
moving all the way over to usb type c
with this being the last ipad to have
lightning and with pressure from europe
and rumors that the iphone will start
getting rid of it i would love to see
apple finish the job and bring usb type
c to this ipad with that said if this is
the case then the budget ipad will also
get the redesigned treatment and have a
modern clean look with a likely price
increase to 399.
well as we know apple has been on a tick
tock cycle for many years now with their
budget ipads upgrading them every single
year with one update being internal like
processor updates and then the following
year making a physical change like going
from a 9.7 inch design to the current
10.2 inch with that long-standing trend
this past september apple should have
kept the a12 soc and instead upgraded
the design to the 10.5 inch body from
the air 3 but they didn't and for the
first time they broke that trend and
instead gave us the a13 which nobody
really asked for the better front
cameras and finally 64 gigabytes of
storage although those leaks of apple
finally ditching their last
non-laminated display had merit though
and we personally believe that
everything was pushed back just like the
oled ipad and the redesigned iphone se
there are just too many part shortages
and price hikes going on right now so it
makes sense for them to consolidate
parts and wait on such big changes so
even though i would love a full redesign
for the budget ipad this most likely
isn't it with that said even though the
difference from 10.2 inches to 10.5
isn't big having that high quality
laminated display is going to be a
significant improvement with better
brightness and much less reflections
with better apple pencil performance as
well and with that the tension ipad can
take the a14 chip from the air and same
with the 5g connectivity included to
become a weird but worthwhile update so
why would apple do this just six months
after launching the ninth generation
ipad well the last few years apple's
been launching ipad pros in the early
spring and budget ipads close to the
iphone time or exactly the same time but
as i mentioned this year we are
expecting the new ipad pros to come out
in the fall along with a ton of other
apple products so this might just be why
they are flipping the budget ipad to
come in the springtime just like they
used to a few years ago and then the
ipad pros in the fall if you want to see
our full 2022 spring launch event check
out that video right over there and
click above to subscribe to help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
this has been max and i will see you in
the next video
[Music]